[Music]
wait me and Westbrook just talking about
how little Bry it's becoming a big
football guy that's right two years old
two years old my kid is two years old
he's gonna be yelling at everybody is he
I think he's gonna be saying Oh bossing
them around telling what to do
are you kidding I have no idea I think
I'm having a girl first
now now my fans say it's not start with
a girl you started my oldest is a girl
yeah and girls are so different than
boys but girls are perfect for the older
child because now she's six my son is
two yeah
now I could talk to her like yo what's
the deal with your brother like he's on
me I know dad he's totally out of
control
I can talk to like she's an adult right
now yeah no I mean it's like your kids
just take on what you do you're saying
your son plays a lot of football now I
feel like my son's just gonna walk up to
people and be like what are you doing
yeah yeah what's going on absolutely
yeah in there announcer voice that would
be perfect if my kid was like hey Dad
the demons are inside like I asked David
before we start we need to settle this
is what you do in the beginning of a
meeting you let the accountant aka the
treasurer aka the Comptroller don't even
think that's the right word establish
the bets
we made some bets last week we did do
you remember any of them cuz I did none
of them neither did I absolutely so one
of the bets we made was that you said
the Cowboys we're gonna beat the
patroness so you owe me a money that's
disappointing that they lost I'm really
I'm really dissipate reott SAR the worst
team ever show me that much they pay our
boys showed me even less but I'm
disappointed about the loss to other
bets we made that we cannot cash out you
bet me obviously enough you bet me also
that the Texans will beat the Patriots
and that is who the Patriots play on
Sunday next week that's a good bet still
a good bet I don't know man is it a
great bet you could be down another
money
that game is in Houston still a great
pet I feel comfortable about that I will
say that will feller against that
Patriots defense could create some
issues they got a couple guys I could
catch the football
and the Patriots have a couple guys on
the back end that can defense and the
other one was that uh and the other one
is that I bet that the Texans wouldn't
make the playoffs and that took a hit
after I know the construction site here
in Medford where we're building a
one-third size replica of Gillette
Stadium that will call Nikhil Harry's
raises stadium get it hashtag sponsored
content hold on let me go somewhere
quiet
that's much better shut up Trevor I'm on
the phone look people are concerned that
we're averaging just 13 points a game in
November but let me ask you this genius
if this was the Red Sox scoring 13
frigging runs a game would you be
concerned I didn't think so
and I just did air quotes on the word
concern by the way but unfortunately I
can't bend my fingers on account of I've
got six replica Super Bowl rings that I
bought at Dick's Sporting Goods spread
around both my index and middle fingers
dude I could have gone pro but college
recruitment as far too political so the
Patriots a 10 and 1 and the only team on
planet earth that could possibly be
throwing them at this point is the one
led by my step-brother Jimmy Garoppolo
who is texting me right now to ask the
hair care tips I don't have any gotta go
and remember it's not Blake jaw loss
it's Blake Jay win but a win for the
Patriots you get the idea shut up Pat
Pat out very happy that Trevor made a
comeback please don't use my office for
personal calls
Pat Pat man Patriots fans are always
throwing those rings around a little bit
I mean why shouldn't I guess you should
but yes that's why you had one like I
said if I had 6 abs you'd see the most
time you would wear a shirt yeah I would
blow my nose in my shirt and I mean I
got it just I'm sweating under my eyes
look at my abs yes if I had 6 do you
know how obnoxious football players are
with the rings that's all they do
anytime I see a football player go on TV
for the first time they're like oh I'm
sorry that my ring is nice Brady
weirdest rings like that Tom Brady is
not sure all I do is think about Tom
Brady is
his rings jumping around like that yes
if I had Super Bowl rings
I would flaunt it ridiculous amount oh
listen I don't know I don't know that to
be true I think you'd be like I'll wear
one ring and maybe I would not be one of
those pros it's like oh I don't even
know where it is
well I'll tell you this you don't how
big those we're not going out Friday
night out of control they're too big
they're gaudy yeah
nobody wants them I was a really good
justification yeah but one thing Pat Pat
said and again I didn't know Popeye was
gonna talk about any of that is Patriots
Niners yes I believe that right now
we're really at a foursome maybe at a
fie some of teams that I think can go to
the NFL Super Bowl okay in Miami
Patriots yes Niners yes Ravens uh-huh
Saints I believe that I I believe that
the Packers can be scary but that roof
that did not look good no no this
Seahawks because of Russell Wilson can
be in every game and I believe that the
Chiefs and Patrick mahomes can be in any
those are like if you had if you did
make me say seven that's my seven but I
really don't think that anyone's messing
with Baltimore New England the Saints or
the Niners if you have to go to there's
place well you've known for teams that
have very good defenses obviously I saw
and really good minded in the running
game so playing defense stopping the run
and running the football in
november/december I mentioned it last
week it's critical to being able to get
to the Super Bowl but I also believe
that Kansas City can get hot
yeah and offensively when you can get
hot at the right time that that
certainly is a problem for I just think
that the the four teams that I said so
this is how I look at it to storyline
wise there's a lot actually man I gotta
save some of this the main thing that I
would say though is if you have to go to
New Orleans good [ __ ] luck yeah
that's too hard to win that's the
Foxborough good luck yeah if the
Patriots have to go to Baltimore where
if Kansas City has to go to Baltimore I
think I think Baltimore's got a huge
edge over Kansas City and I think with
New England it's a it's a coin flip
and actually the
you can get when your would it makes you
say that though because Bella check in
the championship game for me just feels
so the second time they play ball yeah
and he's gonna like he's gonna have a
little bit more gainful Mon Lamar I just
I wouldn't feel that confident either
way that feels like 50/50 right and I
feel more confident in the Ravens
defense stopping the Patriots from
scoring ten points we're saying this is
a Monday Night Football the Rams Ravens
and they let up 40 points but I just
feel more confident with that defense
with their ability to get out the Brady
especially even what we saw yesterday
we didn't see a great showing from that
offense let's get to Bengal tank because
a lot of this is in Bengal tank what
about yeah I think with Russell they can
shock the world yes I just think that
yesterday and that win over the Eagles
that yesterday they looked like we saw
what DK Matt calf could be if he doesn't
catch the ball I'm too big passes and
also like the Eagles offense couldn't
take advantage of it that was so bad but
well they would have scored another at
least 14 points if Metcalfe catches the
ball in the end zone and for some reason
I don't know how this even Russell
Wilson and Patrick mahomes can ruin the
playoffs for anybody they alone well he
overthrew her god it was wide open in
the end zone it was kind of like all
right let's get to Bengal tank to it
welcome back to Bengal tech today's very
special Thanksgiving episode of Bengal
tank is brought to you by the possible
burger it's just a burger and it's [ __ ]
first into the tank left goes offering
an investment in a potential Super Bowl
matchup that might just make one of his
more boisterous listeners so happy that
he finally gets the energy to finish his
zombie screenplay the departed to undead
DiCaprio versus Wahlberg yes that is the
actual title and no he will not budge on
that point
[Music]
all right so you're talking about Super
Bowl matchups I believe I have the one
that is the most entertaining when the
game is played I believe there are
others that have great storylines a few
of which feel like destiny but I believe
there is one Super Bowl matchup that
will be the most entertaining you can
ask me three questions mr. venture
capitalist Brian whispers oh no you have
to kind of guess what I'm going for
which I believe will be the most
entertaining Olsen Super Bowl matchup
okay
from the AEF seat side of things okay
this is question number one does this
team have a good defense yes
so they have a good defense question
number two front of NFC Oh side of
things because I think I have an idea
which way you want to go with that how
good is the quarterback for this team I
would say he's in the top 15 he's
between AES between 8 and 15 8 and 15
okay I'd say he's between 8 and 18 18 18
okay all right question number three
last one I should get four just so we
can do two for NFC and two for AFC just
so you know
fine make question three a two parter
all right question three for both Part A
Part A all right um so I'm thinking
about this team here got that one and I
got that one AFC question okay three how
good is the running side of their often
really strong very strong very okay and
heart B of the third question same thing
for the NOC strong strong okay so I'm
gonna guess okay say we have the guest
portion I'm gonna go the 49ers in the
Ravens and do you buy that as the most
exciting Super Bowl matchup the most
exciting we don't want to see the page
is I think Patrick mahomes be fun but
they don't have a good defense yeah I
would go there you are correct that is
my favorite matchup what does he win a
new pencil I'll have that
from rose I believe that Niners Ravens
yes would be the most fun Super Bowl
Sunday
since Patriots Eagles and then before
that that I can cuz Patriots Eagles was
forty was it was a cycling game but that
would be in the the Kyle Shanahan
offense against the Ravens with Jimmy G
and that running offense against the
Raven cache and against the Ravens and
in Lamar Jackson against that defense I
believe right now would be the best X's
and O Super Bowl also it is a Super Bowl
rematch of the last time Colin
Kaepernick was innocent Lamar Jackson
out there it's gonna be in Miami and
Lamar Jackson is from Miami so that's
gonna be really wild
Kyle Shanahan coming back against like
Oh make Shanahan and Harbaugh might be
the two best coaches in the NFL right
now great matchup but I do not think it
has the best storylines and then the
best story lines is what Pat Pat was
alluding to is that Tom Brady against
the team he grew up rooting for in the
49ers no way Tom Brady versus Jimmy
Garoppolo no Tom Jimmy Garoppolo versus
Bill Belichick who knows all of his
weaknesses it is also Kyle Shanahan
trying to get revenge against the
Patriots for 28 to 3 that it is
Belichick versus Shanahan which is the
best coaching matchup in the NFL I
believe that if that is Tom Brady's last
Super Bowl and he goes out against the
team he grew up rooting for that I
believe is the best storyline Super Bowl
nobody cares about who he rooted for
when he was a child growing up know that
we're gonna see I don't know who the
announcers is it's gonna be like Tom
Brady taking the field and who could
look at this photo 4-year old Tom Brady
wearing a San Francisco Joe Montana
jersey he said it was his dream to play
for the Niners and now remember he once
he did not win Super Bowl 50 didn't make
it there in San Francisco that was
Carolina Denver but I mean it's the best
storyline the best storyline is the most
exciting player in the NFL Lamar Jackson
versus one of the best most
defensive fronts in the NFL that's the
best storyline yeah that's the best X's
and O's but I mean like the Jim Nantz
like do we really care
everybody's are you I have already
haven't seen all the storylines that Tom
Brady could possibly have in a Super
Bowl yeah but if and I've already been
happy but this could have the seven I
might retire because I've already sold
my New England house and going out
against Bill Walsh yeah and the mystique
of the San Francisco 49ers he can do it
every day and then he retires like this
could be the Brady retirement Super Bowl
huh so said that means what it is seven
Brian Westbrook it is the number of
completion not to bring it back to the
Bible but it is so I'm just saying let's
stay there because a - a month ago you
gave me this whole about this essay
about the Saints perfect that is my
second Best Storyline matchup Sean
Payton and the Saints taking on the New
England Patriots
Sean Payton beleaguered we've already
gone into how they were screwed so many
times they even tried to screw him this
weekend with the Carolina Panthers using
his own rule against him prompting Sean
Payton to go not happening
shaking his head vigorously drew Brees
coming back leading it and possibly
going in Miami the place where Drew
Brees could have signed as a free agent
but they didn't clear as medical and he
could be with Nick Saban right now in
the Dolphins but instead they chose
Dante Culpepper making Drew Brees go to
New Orleans and completing his here and
then he retires of Miami because all old
white people retire in Miami that is
true
keep your microphone to yourself sorry
that is and that is why that is the
second best storyline just best one no
no you want to hear this story Tom Brady
Tom Brady it's and his youth no it's
because the Super Bowl is not about
people like us we watch the NFL all year
round right the Super Bowl is for the
other people that don't watch that go
into the next day and go Tom Brady he's
always there that's who the Super Bowl
is for do you think this San Francisco
New England Super Bowl would have more
meaning to Tom Brady you think then they
all may not matter a lot but it's
because Tom Brady team I think it would
also because I think that's a really
really tough matchup and I think San
Francisco what's really interesting is
San Francisco oh this is dangerous I
tried to be honest with you last week be
honest now Wow I just saw something left
go down this go say it not only are the
Niners the perfect matchup for Brady and
Belichick and this team oh my goodness
they are built to be the ultimate
Patriots not just stopper but Patriots
pounder that's true the only way that
you beat Tom Brady is that you can
generate pass rush with your front for
what better front for and this foursome
for the San Francisco 49ers that's true
Kyle Shanahan including that Super Bowl
where you could talk about how he lost
22 three was up 22 3 and hung in the 30s
is averaging about 34 points in the 30s
against Belichick for his career and
will never let up they have an offense
you can't game plan for because it's
kiddo its mustard its Breda its Jeff
Wilson jr. it's Tebow Samuel its Tevin
Coleman you can't game plan for Anders
about him and it's the Richard Sherman
revenge against Tom Brady the dude that
he ran up on and yelled in his face I
think that if the Niners played the
Patriots in the Super Bowl
I can't believe I'm saying this not only
they're gonna win they're gonna win by
double digits the Niners then if the
Niners play the Patriots in Miami they
will win that game by more than a
touchdown more than more than ten what
how do you say that I don't know why
it's coming out of me but it's not I
don't know why it's coming out of you
right now because you warned me I know
but I'm to say these I'm saying the
Patriots can get to the Superbowl you
said they wouldn't get out of the AFC
I'm saying they're gonna get there and
if it's the Niners they're gonna lose by
double digits
[ __ ] I don't want to say that the Niners
have that type of defense we have
everything that can be scary too easy
period yes cuz they can rush for and the
key to beating the Patriots like the
Giants did years ago but like the Eagles
did a couple years ago is getting
pressure with four that's what I'm
saying being able to cover with seven
that's what I'm saying
and Tom break that that defense is
playing on a different level
crowd Rob assala they're their defensive
coordinator people are making way too
much out of the fact that he gets
excited after gay I love that I think
that's pretty cool but because it
energizes the players but that style of
defense is is awesome I never know how
to credit defensive coordinators that
have a lot of talent like I look at Greg
Williams at the Jets right now and what
he's doing having the number one run
defense in the NFL and they don't really
have that much talent and I've got a ton
of injuries that's incredible but like
the Niners d-line and I mean it is what
I got a bit they've developed first
round pigs I think Fred Warner certainly
should be a he's been playing great I
can't believe I said that
secondary he's been aggressive but they
take the shape of the defensive
coordinator and I'm gonna say this one
last thing whoever gets home-field
advantage in the NFC is who I believe is
coming out of the NFC because I believe
that every other team is screwed if Drew
Brees now if Drew Brees has to go to San
Francisco or I think it's gonna be an
amazing match up but I I still think
that Drew Brees outside is a little bit
of a different animal the fact that the
Niners are going to New Orleans in two
weeks to get a taste of the Super Dome
in the regular season even if they lose
I think that's enormous that's what I
want the Rams last year the Rams went to
New Orleans got the brakes peed off of
them and then went back in the playoffs
and won because Jimmy needs to get a
taste of the Superdome before it's
playoff time because it will shock you
and if either team has to go to Green
Bay which I don't think they're gonna
have to do now I think that would have
been troubling but I don't know that
defense seems like it you can go on a
road it'll win I can't even say that I
tried to stop you several times I said
stop pump your brakes
don't
go there but you did it last week I know
because we you are saying the same thing
that I'm saying that's why I told you
not to go there but now you're in the
same boat with me I got kid I'll play
with a broken ankle dicing up people the
best best Titan in the league obviously
but it's much more to his game I hope by
the way that everybody fan I hope that
everybody's saying all this to kiddo
because I am friends of kiddo and I'm
friends with Kelsie and I really hope
that Kelsey's getting pissed because I
will say this George Kittel is
phenomenal yes phenomenal but he is
nowhere near the receiver love Kelsey
and I am hoping that this motivates
Kelsey because there's something about
tight ends when you say that one is a
better blocker yeah it's like saying
they're more of a man uh-huh
it's like Sarah liner right and he is
yes I have stood next to both both of
them are huge but Kelsey is a much
larger man and so I'm hoping I'm not
saying he's better I would take kettle
right now and I would say Kelsey man you
guys are [ __ ] incredible right now I
take it a little bit more but I'm hoping
that it pisses Kelsey off Kittel was
more physical after he gets the ball
Kelsey is physical to it he he seems
like Kelsey but Kelsey also has a 50/50
advantage absolutely if you lob it up
Kelsey I trust you more than Kendall
yeah I also think that Kelsey can be
used a little bit more in the running
game if that makes sense
I think he's better at the shovel passes
and stuff than Kittel is well they did I
believe that I agree that Kittel is more
dangerous with with the ball and as a
kid was a tad bit faster and I think
he's a much better run blocker much much
better to run block I don't know if
those are things that matter I think you
put Kelsey in space it's just hard to
defend that because he's that special
but kiddo
he's been powerful he runs guys over in
the secondary stiff-arms them hey listen
you're this small small amount I think
kid is a little bit better alright I
hope nobody clips out that Patriots
thing and put it on the Internet yeah
cuz gonna be bad luck for you brother I
don't care anymore
all bad let's go to right back to the
Bengal tank that's one good buy for me
next up into the tank let go believes
one player not currently on a playoff
team will single-handedly change the
entire playoff picture
a few hits he plays for a team based in
North America he prefers cleats to
flip-flops when playing football and he
has both a first and last name hmm
there's a great hint some of the worst
sense I've ever heard before my life
actually
like literally I'm no closer to guessing
this than I was before those three here
all right
Westbrook venture capitalist first and
last you get three questions for class
so you you don't give anything you
offered nothing I will say that this guy
what he has done in the second half of
seasons is not going talked about enough
he's a defensive player
I have not is that one of your three
questions no that's like I'm just gonna
say that this is a guy that is he in the
AFC North are these real question oh
these are just just kind of talking out
loud
alright cuz normally you don't have the
discipline not to give me a lie am I am
going a little bit off of Evan Silva on
this one he started talking about it in
Merced isn't this guy incredible I said
yes I will give you a few hints that he
is in the AFC he was traded doing he is
on offense I will now give you three
questions cuz that is more than enough
okay he's on offense he's not on a
playoff team right now no but in the
next five weeks
he is playing three teams in the AFC
that are in the playoff hunt I do not
believe his team actually is and one
team in the NFC playoff hunt and I
believe that he is performing at such a
high level it could really mess a few of
them up so why don't you ask the running
back yeah do you know it I don't know it
but I have a feeling all right my spidey
senses question is he in the AFC South
yeah just say his name now well I mean
you're his son first of all he were
great
that was some of the worst hand Taylor
so there in the AFC South he's already
back is he taller than six - yeah just
say his name Derek Henry
do you agree why are you so upset at my
success this game is really fun when I
win Oh No every now that I have to win
to know who the name of this game is I
win so Evan Silva has been a little bit
of a tear lately and it's funny because
it's one of those things where you go
WOW every year Derek Henry maybe doesn't
play great in the first yeah eight weeks
and then every time I watched and read
it so at the end of the year it's Derek
Henry 80-yard touchdown Derek Henry
touchdown easily explain so here are
some stats that Silva has following on
Twitter out of and Silva he's the man he
one time compared me to Joe Rogan so
he's in my heart forever career
touchdowns in September and October for
Derek Henry ten career touchdowns in
November and December 24 yeah that's 2.4
x that's wild also this is from rich
rebar who writes for Warren sharps
website Derek Henry's last 16 games
played 1600 rushing yards for 5.3 yards
a carry 18 rushing touchdowns 19 catches
209 yards to receiving touching boots
and when you look at the schedule of the
team's they play this could be really
interesting they play at Indianapolis in
a dome that Colt defense has been a lot
better ever since they got crazy Darius
Leonard backs right Oakland the Texans
twice and versus the Saints at home
there's something about the Saints if
they're still fighting for a one-seat
having to go to Tennessee and and Derek
Henry just beating them up for an
afternoon even if it's not even if it's
not a win just getting pounded by Derek
Henry yeah but the fact that the Texans
have to play him twice and I went back
and looked and the Texans have had
success against Derek Henry they've also
lost some unspeakable games to the
Titans but if the Texans have to face
Derek Henry and we saw Whitney Merciless
getting beat up on Thursday they already
don't have JJ Watt now DJ readers been
great
I just think Derek Henry
can be one of those guys and quietly the
last two games the Titans have put up 77
points against the Chiefs and the
Jaguars I think Derek Henry could be one
of these AFC Player of the weeks a few
times and really mess up the playoffs
for a few - two points the texans
without JJ Watt have given up over an
average of 169 yards per game
nice that's without him now with them
obviously they were low they were giving
up 85 yards to shore he makes a big
difference but the biggest point and why
I say that it's predictable that Derek
Henry has had so much success
the latter part of the season yeah it's
his size I met the kid when he was in
high school you came down to the Maxwell
Awards
six years I've ever seen 6-3 to 50 at
the time I saw him maybe last year he
was 64 250 huge at this point in the
season the team's that are getting ready
for a playoff push especially you got 9
10 wins now you started making decisions
like okay I what I can't do is get hurt
now but I can't do is afford to say you
know what I got a nagging injury going
into the playoffs so now I'm making
business decisions and the one thing I
don't want to do at the end of the year
when it's cold when I'm already being
dinged up just a little bit
it's hackles 6-4 to 50 I don't want that
trouble and what you saw yesterday
trouble in that game was guys just
saying you know what I'm not getting
away I'm gonna run just slow enough then
I could try to get him with an arm
tackle and not tackle and just make sure
that I look good on tape mmm we saw that
game at the game and they replayed what
he did last year against uh who was it
he did last year
Jackson Jacksonville again he owns
charge same dog little thing in
Jacksonville normally has a nasty run
defense but not against that guy the
other thing is too is a big man
Ryan Tannehill is kind of providing a
spark again he's big to them and the
thing is is Mariota was mobile but
Tannehill is more willing it seems like
to run I do not want to spend a lot of
time breaking down the Titans because I
think that they're they're just gonna be
a very annoying team I also think what's
interesting about the Titans and the
reason they can make life really hard
for these teams down the stretch is
their defense as a whole their defense
is really really good I just
gonna get an official number on where
they are the Tennessee Titans right now
they're 17th in total yards pass this is
not good great but their run defense
yeah their run defense of 13th it's
Derrick Henry I just think what he does
to you where he beats you up and then
also could be a little spark right now I
think you'd be dangerous and Ryan
Tannehill runs the ball a little bit too
and he's a big kid he looks big in the
pocket when he's back there in the palm
knock it up
I don't Ryan Tannehill is gonna get paid
and it's gonna be funny yeah of course
man you should get paid he's probably
well this year you should get paid he
should get paid I just don't want my
team being the one to pay Tennessee is
gonna pay him no choice they got a
pinion I heard some people saying they
might do a franchise tag possibly this
is see what he has well why do you have
a problem with that I don't know you say
well imagine Ryan Tannehill with 24
million dollars for one season kind of
sounds crazy not Teddy Bridgewater and I
got when I got the best running backs I
got Christian McCaffrey making like
Knight well that's cuz running backs are
respected as they should be running
backs matter they they do matter and
look at Carolina it's a great example of
that look at Green Bay a great example
of that you can't put it all on your
quarterback shoulders get the ball
running back they do matter big
difference look at San Francisco look at
all those team that you talked about
that could play in the Super Bowl
New England yesterday they got their run
game going they know what's happening
yeah November December can't you run the
football can you stop the run that's
gonna dictate who's gonna win the game
yeah Kevin Curtis gets his 200 yard game
in September yeah November uh-huh
it's simple you win you you start off
you get into the playoffs in fantasy
with wide receivers that's right and you
win the championship with running backs
run it down their nose run it out right
down there was it right there I've never
heard run it down put it down there
maybe run it down their nose all right
last bengal tank where we going to 4 to
4 Westie damn and finally into the tank
there's one particular coach who's on
the hot seat but Lefko says he might
have dug himself out of his own home it
really hurts him to say but if you're
unable to stuff a bunch of food and
1990s computer then I would be glad to
Philadelphia who am I talking about I
have no idea this segment has gone off
the rails Bengal tank that is umber
getting really high and mighty after
saying Baltimore yeah last last week and
then he went with Phil Adelle for yeah
yeah yeah I appreciate it though
I didn't even know that that filling a
computer with things could be turned
into a city that was great I believe
there is a coach that I think some
people are gonna put on the hot seat and
I'm asking you if you buy that he should
stay this term and should I buy that he
should get three questions you are
buying that this coach currently
beleaguered currently losers of two
straight should stay you have three
questions all right
there are they in the AFC no so they're
in the end of CO two questions left
they've lost two straight correct sir
do they have a good quarterback yes a
good do you say top ten I didn't hear
you you asked me good quarterback with
that that would meaning tough I would
say when he's playing well people could
say he's top five when he's playing but
I would say saying top ten is is
typically where he is sometimes he's not
playing at that level sometimes he is
okay do they have had they won a Super
Bowl in the last five years
[ __ ] no they had oh that's all your
questions damn I was not expecting that
okay who are you gonna guess I was I
mean I think the obvious answer could
have been the Eagles alright so are you
gonna buy you don't know who it is I
like you buying or not based on if you
don't know but I also think you could
have easily said the Dallas Cowboys
alright so am i buying what what's the
question in my barn buying this coach
that he should stick around
not know it was jasonncaryn yeah he's
damn he's out of there this is Brian
Westbrook's best showing of all time hey
man I focused today focused as you were
watching that game what did you think
about I guess the the main call that
everyone that I would like to talk about
which is Jason Garrett kicking a field
goal down seven was six minutes left
from the eight yard line yeah well I
think at that point based upon what
you've seen you're off I mean you're
honest truth did you go you should kick
this or so here's here's the scenario he
had three timeouts you're down seven six
minutes ago at some point you're gonna
say I think my defense can get a stop
but the truth is we really didn't see
the defense getting any stops all game
long
no it's like Miss throws by Brady
they're gonna hire wide or maybe the
defense has been against bad fits in a
run game I'm talking about Shawn Lee
going inside when he's outside he should
be outside and contain I just think that
in have fan duress yeah I think the the
truth is and quite honestly I think the
best coaching decision if your defense
was able to get a stop which they
weren't would be to kick it you have six
minutes left and three timeouts that's
the right coaching decision but based
upon the way that my defense is played
and quite honestly based upon the way my
offense had played my ability to get
back down there was just not very good
especially throwing the football our
best receiver ended up the game with
zero catches so I think I probably would
have went for it
but I think the right coaching decision
probably is to kick the field goal and
extend the game a little bit more make
it a longer situation because if you if
you don't kick let's say you don't get
it right and they go down they drive the
field in 82 92 yards and score then the
game is over even a field goal it's even
if they drive is 60 yards the game is
over two people with the field goal as
somebody that bet the Cowboys plus six
that's a good bet I have never been in a
situation where that dream has come true
yeah I have rooted for a lot of teams
down seven to kick the field goal
knowing that it is the worst real
football decision that you can make the
worst why but they won me the bet why
would he say is the worst
I am gonna go light on Jason Garrett
because Jason Garrett what you did I
believe should go down in the NFL
betting Hall of Fame the down seven plus
six bet in which you kick the field goal
that really the only reason you do that
is if your truck bed the game and I'm
not gonna sit here and accuse Jason
Garrett of betting the Cowboys plus six
and taking it I would never do that but
there is no reason for you to do that
why your offense has had zero to little
success at all game you have not been in
this part of the field all game being
down a touchdown versus being down a
touchdown doesn't [ __ ] matter you
either go for it or you plan earlier in
the drive let's say the first down of
that series and say instead of thinking
that we're gonna kick it let's act like
we're going for it on fourth down so
instead of running that play on third we
try and get three or four yards to get
ourselves a more possible fourth down I
am NOT gonna go really hard on Jason
Garrett that he said after the game that
they don't speak to analytic people the
same week that an article came out on
the athletic that the Baltimore Ravens
not only craft a game plan and practice
situational game flow with their head
analytical people but they will tell him
win probabilities during the drive and
on the plays I am NOT going to focus on
the fact that Jason Garrett seems
completely ill-prepared for any of these
situations I'm not even gonna focus on
the fact that in the morning
Ian Rapoport reported that if Jason
Garrett is fired that the New York
Giants are a likely landing spot one
that he quote approves of clearly being
released by either the JA excuse me
Cowboys or Garrett because the Giants
had no comment
Cobb and I don't know why thank you I
don't know why the Cowboys would leak
that out you know and I'm not gonna say
that Jason Garrett likely should have
been fired today after Jerry Jones came
out and said we got outcoached he didn't
wear the fact that they were
ill-prepared on multiple special teams
plays and this has been going on for a
decade I'm not gonna focus on that
I'm just gonna say Jason Garrett thank
you because I have never seen a coach
kick a field goal when I have a team
plus six and they're down seven I've
always wanted it to happen I never knew
it would happen and for that I say thank
you and I'm not gonna talk about all
that others don't even mention it not if
you should bring them up Tony and bring
it up I'm gonna bring I still think it
was the right coaching decision so
analytically it's proven that you're
very wrong
yeah because what's the advantage well
the advantage so you go down four so
then you go okay so then we still have
to stop the Patriots to get the ball
back and now they're gonna punt it
likely and we're gonna start within our
own 20 where we have to stop the
Patriots anyway so let's say we don't
even get it and now it's on the seven
and they they go three and out which you
have to anyway now you're likely getting
the ball to 40 well the reason why I
would kick is because you extend the
likelihood of the game so I think you're
extending the minimization of the loss I
don't know the game is extended
well it's extended because if let's say
you don't get it let's just write on
that premise you don't get the the
touchdown there on fourth down okay so
you're still down seven they have the
ball in the eighth and they drive 60
yards okay which they have the
capability you do you're playing against
the greatest quarterback of a long time
then they get a field goal right so now
you're down ten so what you're doing
though is you're guarding against the
loss and I think that my issue in the
NFL are there are some coaches that are
focusing on win probability and there
are some coaches that don't even realize
that they're focusing on losing
probability and then there are more
coaches out there that are going how do
we not lose instead of how do we win for
example I'm watching the ESPN pregame
show and they're saying if the Browns
win this game their chance of making the
playoffs is 70% if they lose it's 18%
and they're like don't lose no [ __ ]
if you're if you're lose prick you are
trying to win the game and if you have a
better chance of going for a fourth if
you get that your win probability
skyrockets what was it for fin what
eight fourth and seven orphan salmon but
the real thing is that a lot of second
down they should have done different and
that and that indictment of Jason
Cassidy as they should have done but
also in that situation look I don't want
to blame it all on Garrett
there was a huge third down conversion
on that last try of the call taken away
by a phantom tripping pen that's right
and we could wax poetic about how the
referees are wildly inconsistent at the
same point the Cowboys best chance to
score was there inside the 10 and I
don't want to lose track of that because
of an injury of a penalty that would
have given the ball on their own fort
we'll see here's here's the other part
did you have to look at and I agree that
it was their best chance to score but
Tom Brady in our office hadn't looked
great all year but I mean all game hit
him inside their own five maybe maybe
you get the ball on the 50 60 let's say
let's say you get the ball on the 50
right you pin them inside they don't get
the first time you get the ball on fifth
you still have to drive down I could you
can make that argument I just think that
if they somehow get a p.i penalty after
50 let's say they you don't get the
touchdown and they ain't the Patriots
end up getting a pipe in OT a long one
now it makes it a much easier kick for
that for me makes it ain't out of out of
hand for me kicking that field goal is
like when defenses play prevent in a two
minute
mm-hm and you're going we are preventing
a touchdown but you're really just
suffering a slow death and so I think
taking the field goal means you die
slower whereas if you go for the
touchdown you can flip it around like
that and I think we've entered a world
Westbrook of football where it's been
proven that the more aggressive teams
that are actively trying to win the
Baltimore's the Niners the Saints the
teams that go for it on fourth down like
the Saints in that game where the the
crazy call happened
the reason the Panthers were in a
position to get that pass interference
is because Sean Payton went for fourth
and one on his own 45 it's different
though for prett one in four for seven
are hugely different
they still had an opportunity at seven
on the eight yeah but they also had an
opportunity where they had the ball
because they force the Patriots dick
punt the reason these masters were able
to beat the Patriots is they were the
team that went for it on those fourth
downs do you remember on the
game-winning drive yeah that Zach Ertz
caught they also had a fourth and seven
I think at their own thirty and they got
it on a slant to Earths I remember
because I looked around the Patriots
fans when we got that I said you're
[ __ ]
no you need you need to go that wasn't a
game that was gonna be decided 13 to 9
this game didn't have a bunch of offense
yet but to me it's even more so because
if you thought that you were gonna put
together a 60 yard seven yard drive
against the Patriots then usually you
hadn't done a no game you should be
fired for that you should be fired for
that like if you thought you know what I
got faith then I'm gonna tell you that
Amari Cooper has zero catches your best
offense has been end arounds to Tony
Paulo right and that dak doesn't have it
because it's raining and it's windy out
and if you believe that you could do it
again then you should be fired on that
all hours of thought that you just had a
with a play 78 yard drive right well pin
them will kick the field goal with Penry
40 will get it off was Randall Cobb and
the big play and it almost was a fumble
yeah almost so you get the field goal
right this is a thought
so now mr. 39 you get the field goal you
pin them deep you get the ball at the 50
let's say you get it at the 40 you get
another big play now you have that
chance to go in win the football game
that is playing aggressively but my
thing is is this whole what-if game
because I heard Orlovsky saying this on
ESPN this morning two of if they get it
they stop them they go that's a whole
lot of [ __ ] that I don't have faith in I
don't have faith in the Cowboys stopping
them because they didn't that's true I
didn't have faith in the Cowboys driving
hey you're just coming off a long drive
though so you're coming off at Long John
what's wild is I would have liked it
more if Garrett kicked the field goal
and then kicked an onside kick give
yourself a chance to get it back there
if you don't you got to stop him anyway
your dad and you just gave yourself and
feel great for a time that way no what
are you talking about no because if you
kick an onside kick and the Patriots get
it and let's say you stop them cuz you
have to when they kick a field goal
alright now you're down seven you get
the ball back which is what you were
saying and so you write for the tie in
this way if you go down and score out
there having 13 and 9 you're playing for
the win cuz you still got a score
touchdown you're playing for a win not a
tie I I in their house you're playing
for a win later
I personally even they got that
touchdown right this score still tied
yes and they still haven't stopped the
Patriots all game yeah but now
if you stop you just get a kick field
goal if you stop him yeah yeah I mean
you have to stop a man you gotta get a
field goal anywhere I know I just I I
think that it really really feels like I
don't know where that [ __ ] Jason
Garrett story came out Sunday morning
like I don't know how like you know
where it came no no but I know that from
Jerry but why would Jerry put out that
the Giants are sorted in Jason Garrett I
I don't know who Jason Garrett's agent
is so you think that Jason Garrett agent
man who does this was it Ben who does a
benefit hmm well it depends I don't know
if because I know that I was in here
yesterday with a Giants fan and he went
if we sign Jason Garrett and in my head
I guess the Eagles fan if Jason Garrett
doesn't leave the division goes to the
Giants let's [ __ ] go that sounds
amazing
but it the writing is on the wall that
the to me the only way Jason Garrett
keeps his job is if they go to the Super
Bowl and I don't even know if they went
the Super Bowl and loss to the Patriots
again he might still get fired no way if
they making such a Super Bowl he
definitely keeps his job but based upon
that defense that I've seen in the last
few weeks they're not getting well he is
the offensive guy well you know he's the
he's the UM Tomlin I I'm the head coach
that I have an offensive background and
I sometimes go in that room but I'm a
head coach yeah and the thing is I
respect Jason Garrett but like his
quotes after the game about not using
analytics was further proof of the one
area he's super inept in I feel like he
wouldn't you know they say some people
are before their prime or before their
time and after the time like you were
before your time right like if you came
ten years later you'd be [ __ ]
Christian McCaffrey right like Jason
Garrett has actually post his time Jason
Garrett would have been a phenomenal
coach of the 90s he said he doesn't use
analytics at all he said that during the
game he doesn't have people in his ear
being like hey if you go for it here
your win probability is 40 but if you
kick the field goal of drops 10 to 30
they don't do that where the best teams
the NFL do yeah they they they certainly
had a chance to win that game when you
think about Cooper Gallup Cobb Zeke and
dak who's playing whether the best seen
as he's ever had you think that you're
going to school
the nine points period period held the
Eagles core ten do they have none of
those weapons yeah so you just kind of
figure especially going there against a
team that has been really good against
the past but is susceptible to some runs
you think that you got a chance to at
least run the ball a little bit better
and scored more than nine points here's
my other issue and I'm gonna bring this
back to the Eagles because that's where
we need to finish I'm very tired of
teams playing the Patriots and the
Patriots the only team that runs trick
plays yeah you are playing the Patriots
the only way that you have a chance of
winning is unleashing the bag and using
everything you got
there is no let's save it for week 15
everyone in this league is huge and the
Patriots or the Seahawks used a trick
play against the Eagles because Pete
Carroll is good in big games he gets it
Kyle Shanahan has not just one but seven
trick plays for you Sean Payton has five
trick plays for you Sean McVeigh has
about two he doesn't have as many as I'd
like it's not really where I'd want it
to be right now but I'm tired of these
traditional coaches just saying we got
to do what we got to do to beat him
you're also a little bit scared Matt my
floor said at halftime in that blowout
by the Niners we're not going to change
what we're doing because if we did we're
gonna lose by more if you are not
adjusting anything at halftime and
you're being a seventy-year-old all ball
coach down at the local high school
saying we're gonna do what we do better
than anybody does what they do then get
the hell out of here when you play the
Patriots you're scared to do trick plays
because if you make one mistake the game
gets out of hand
the Patriots have done this for years
they've capitalized on other teams
mistakes and so you're scared as a head
coach and I'm not saying that I would be
because just to your point that made
those trick plays maybe the only reason
that you got a chance the reason why the
Ravens beat up on the Patriots so much
not because the trick plays because it
was a trickery of Lamar Jackson about
the history of the Patriots and the
Ravens the Ravens were always the team
doing flea flickers true to the pain
they were the team bringing out tight
ends and playing them at tackle well the
reason and here's a reason why the
Eagles be kind of citrus because of the
Philly the Patriots are so fundamentally
sound that when you do trick plays it
breaks all of the rules there's so sound
the rules are just that's how they live
they operate in ten yards 12 yards 15
yards I'm opposed to be outside I got
secured to outside arm that all the
trick plays break all the rules that's
why you they will never forget
after the Falcons Patriots Super Bowl I
was texting with Sims when they go up 28
to 3 and I was like forget the Falcons
offense it's Kyle he's gonna know their
rules how is the Falcons defense doing
this to the Patriots and he said they're
playing a defense they've never played
before yep let's got it my thing is this
if you're gonna play Belichick you need
to know yourself you need to self scout
and know what are my tendencies and then
how do I not do that against them and if
and I understand that's really tough on
one week to change everything that you
believe in and your DNA and I get it
they are a two if not three week
preparation team but like the teams that
face this team in the playoffs if if it
is the Ravens and they know that there
could be the Patriots and they could
start dealing the bye week a little bit
or they do have an extra week if you are
facing the Patriots and you don't play
an offense and a defense completely
unlike that you normally do and you
don't have two or three plays that's why
I'm excited if it is saints or Niners
and the Super Bowl cuz Sean Payton's
gonna draw some things out here and Kyle
Shanahan's gonna drop some things up I
remember playing the Patriots in the
Super Bowl and all season long they've
been to 314 we are practicing so there's
two weak leads how much for the game
we're practice against the three for all
we put them up for the past two weeks we
come out the first play they're playing
two for three and we're like what and
the hell just happened all the stuff
that we practice for hours upon hours
two hours a day is out the window
because they're playing a totally
different defense than we expected
exactly and it was crazy and my thing is
it shouldn't be crazy you have to be
able to address adjust team but also
like like that's why I think you know
Sean McVeigh
I watched so many games of game film
last year and city over prepared because
Belichick has to get in your head yeah
that you could be like he's played this
incredible defense all year but what if
he comes out in base four six and you
have no idea that he's been slowly every
practice hey guys we're gonna do five
minutes on the four six yeah you know
the fact that the story came out and I
really hope that Belichick actually
didn't do any of this but he says it
just to [ __ ] with people that they the
year before the interception against the
Seahawks that he practiced goal line
defense every single day and at that
moment it just led to that and he had no
idea but it just he gets in people's
heads but in my mind you know it's like
if you're you're playing poker or you're
playing somebody in basketball you're
anticipating the move that they think
you're going and link but with Belichick
it's like okay you're gonna do that
movie I'm gonna do this and you can go
like seven layers he's already thought
it he's already thought it and what he
does well good the crazy part is that
when you talk about halftime and the
floor not wanting to change anything
Belva checks changing things in between
series and at the quarter marks somebody
not just a NASA and I don't know who it
isn't I apologize but it was the
scariest thing in sports is seeing Bill
Belichick write something down on the
sidelines when he takes that pencil out
and makes a note someone's being
eliminated right something is about to
be executable way you're either gonna
lose points or they're gonna gain points
but it he's nothing like but he did get
something wrong what did he get wrong
the running back rankings on the NFL top
100 of all time oh okay did you see this
list I have not seen the complete list
No now a lot of people are saying that
it's Belichick and it's gotta be right
and all that stuff they have been they
did running backs on Friday okay and in
studio they had Emmitt Smith and Jim
Brown all-time leading rusher okay and
who many believe is the greatest running
back of all time yeah now these were the
names that were put on the list
I believe they're doing like a hundred
greatest players and I think they did
twelve running backs okay
Jim Brown Earl Campbell Eric Dickerson
Walter Payton Barry Sanders Gale Sayers
Oh Jay Simpson Emmitt Smith Steve Van
Buren mm-hmm he goes okay Lenny more
marion motley earl Dutch Clark okay
the youngest running back in that crew
is Emmitt Smith right and he was 15
years ago from today where he retired in
Arizona no Adrian Peterson hmm no
LaDainian Tomlinson no Marshall Faulk a
host of anybody that's played in the
last two decades and Belichick the one
that I think a lot of people been
focusing on is the guy that played in
the 30s Earl Dutch Clark Kerr who
Belichick said was one of the great
two-way players and most versatile
players to ever play the game
and I'm just gonna say this this
romanticizing of the two-way player I
get it when I grew up hearing about
Chuck Bednarik and now he was the best D
lineman in the game and the best old
lineman in the game I said wow what a
warrior if Jerome Bettis played in the
30s he would be the greatest defensive
lineman that's ever lived
and the best running back of all time
absolutely
I watched the eight clips they found of
Earl Dutch Clark and you know when
you're watching clips of Jim Brown you
go it's incredible he makes everybody
else look like a newspaper sales Earl
Dutch Clark looked like one of those
newspaper salesman one of his highlights
was a dropkick it was a dropkick Wow and
my thing is we talk all the time about
greatest and best none of those guys can
compete this was from Dave finocchio
former founder of elite sport we were
texting about that this weekend he said
there is definitely a best versus
greatest where you know is there really
been anyone better than Adrian Peterson
in terms of best I don't know man he
really had every
thing but greatest may have been Walter
Payton you know what I mean and and his
example in the MBA was that Bill Russell
is arguably the greatest right ten
championships twelve years all that but
Michael Jordan might be the best and he
might also be the greatest that's how
good he was but these names I don't
think you can leave out the last twenty
years man
how could you but and I wanted to hear
your perspective that actually played
that's my rant no no I think you're
right it was interesting point about
Earl Dutch Clark his last two seasons he
was a player coach can you imagine that
like yeah yeah yeah we're gonna run
these place for me first and then we'll
try to get you involved quarterback a
little bit later but that's that's
pretty cool okay fine can you fire
someone on your own team if you're the
player we're fine we're firing Carson
wins today now being crime out but
that's pretty cool but here's my thought
about the list I don't think you put
Adrian Peterson or that white yet
because he's not finished playing it
right
that's why but Marshall Faulk certainly
should be on there l'Damian certainly
should be on there there those are two
no brainers right off the top of my head
I think both of those guys deserve to be
on there right now because Marshall
actually changed the game we talked
about Christian McCaffrey right now we
talking about camara down there in New
Orleans he changed how people have used
view running backs back in the day it
was 43 in two running backs set in
Marshall Faulk what he did was got this
place guys outside in the slot position
we even out lied it made a line back and
go check him and he just tore it up and
he opened the gates for guys like me
that were able to say you know what now
we need to get just get our running back
in space with the linebacker then what
happens with defenses now they say we're
not gonna go base defense anymore we're
not gonna play with three linebackers
we're gonna play with two and a nickel
guy just just because if they displace
their running back we won't have a
faster guy out there and you still see
guys like Christian McCaffrey still
doing this thing you saw David Johnson a
couple years ago yeah when this thing so
I certainly think there Marshall should
be on there I think LaDainian and his
ability to score touchdowns just for
that alone was was excellent which
interest everyone focuses on this is
definitely a recency bias and there's
totally ageism and
a huge part of me that doesn't care
about that old part and I do I read a
book about the history of football and
how it started in steel mills and really
it it took people like that but to
compare it nowadays is crazy but it's
not just comparing the guy from the 30s
to the guy from mm I don't think Emmitt
Smith is the top three running back in
the last 30 years if you want me to be
real Emmitt put up a lot of yards it
would take Marshall Faulk over Emmitt
okay I would take Adrian Peterson over
Emmitt okay I would take LaDainian
Tomlinson over Emma okay I would take
Thurman Thomas over Emmitt they played
in the same decade well I know the guy
kept playing yeah
but I'm feeling a little bit the way I
feel about I know he's better than Frank
Gore okay but he was I don't think Emmet
was was he always was he ever the best
running back in it I am it may go so had
a fight with Emmitt at Super Bowl three
years I hear it coming out at you right
now
and so we've never been cool since but
then we did see each other at amigos be
a good guy I've always liked him he's
always been really really cool go back
and watch the YouTube video it is on
YouTube on the left I show we had him at
Super Bowl in Minnesota and he just got
yelled at by a group of Eagles fans and
I told him I was one and he said that we
were a bunch of dogs that didn't know
how to win okay and we went up and back
and he got so heated and he had his
little chest hair out and he was like
insulting me that we don't even know how
to win even if we will want it's only
1:00 right right but I still and this is
removing all of that bias away am I
wrong to say that he's not even a top
three running back in the last year base
is it on today's offenses that's what
you're basing it on back of him when
Emmitt and some of the 90s now it was
hard yeah you throw if we put Adrian
Peterson yeah behind that Dallas
offensive line in the 90s he may have
run for 3000 I agree but Adrian Peterson
if we put Barry Sanders he's retired
he's on this list as well we know that
Barry was a different case we put
LaDainian or Marshall behind that
offensive line yeah I think would have
3,000 yards I agree but here's the thing
Emmitt played through injuries the
longevity derivatively with I mean those
are the special things about Emmett and
you can't
I mean listen all the carries that he
had all the yards that he racked up in
Super Bowls coming back from from from
being off for a couple weeks because of
holdouts and winning Super Bowls that
was impressive that was made Emmitt
great he certainly should be on this
list I think all those guys are you
talking about our great running backs
you put great running board behind
great offensive lines they're gonna be
special the thing that always that
doesn't take away with em it was they
let me let me explain this the thing
that always happens is you say somebody
is like the seventh best running back of
all time and people are like he hates
this guy right the true thing is is the
fact that you're in the conversation
means you're one of the greatest who
have ever played I believe that
sometimes greatness is situational well
that's true
you know like Terry Bradshaw was a great
quarterback he also had almost as many
as interceptions as touchdowns but he
was on the Steel Curtain and they won
four Super Bowls right you know like if
Phil Simms went to the Niners instead of
Joe Montana and they flipped they might
still each win a Super Bowl maybe but
who the hell knows right and the fact
that Brady went to the Patriots you know
what I mean the fact that Dwayne Haskins
has to play on Washington where if
Dwayne Haskins went to New England he'd
have a completely different career I
just think that that Emmitt Smith went
to the perfect situation perfect storm
yeah it was a perfect storm from him I'm
just looking at the list of all the
great running backs and I have so much
admiration for these guys obviously Oh
Jay Eric Dickerson Marshall Faulk
Marshall Marcus Allen also a little
funny thing is if you look at the image
the NFL put out boy they're trying to
hide oj oath of course they have they
got Oh Jay is like half an eyeball
you're like oh I see a Buffalo Bills
logo Curtis Martin is the one that old
Jack's never mentioned Fred Taylor well
he's never mentioned he should be
because Fred Taylor was a load big and
fast and powerful what was what is your
answer and James what was your look at
me hurt us Martin I think watching him
because I don't think I ever appreciated
him enough I think he was special and I
don't have the numbers I don't know how
many yards he rushed for but he's up
there I mean he had over 12,000 yards
obviously I think in in his career but
he was special he carried teamwork 10101
fourth all-time at the time so now I
think he's probably down the fifth now
that Francoeur has jumped up in my mind
12,000
is that line that kind of separates you
from greatness twelve thirteen thousand
and it's just not a lot of guys that
have had much more than that but I think
that Curtis Martin Martin was special he
was able to catch the ball out of the
backfield he wasn't a powerful powerful
runner but he can run you over from time
to time or he had good speed I mean I
think he was exactly what will work in
today's in the film right now
I think Edgerrin James and his
productivity was special when he was
with the codes I mean there's a bunch of
good running backs in the league you
named a bunch of them but you know I
certainly believe that when you separate
time errors because there was a time
where everyone was the same size and
then you had guys like Jim Brown that
was bigger than everybody else sure of
course he had a bunch of yards but
nowadays the running backs are normally
smaller than everyone else so let's say
from the 90s on should probably have a
list and when you start talking about
that list Adrian Peterson certainly is
on that obviously all the guys I just
mentioned certainly are on that list as
well go sailing yet I mean I mentioned
Marcus Marcus
oh you did yeah Toro Davis I mean I
think Terrell Davis was a good running
back short career similar to Gale Sayers
but he had a couple Super Bowls which
made his his career impactful Corey
Dillon man not so much Eddie George
priest Holmes was really really an iron
out as to that those are different
classes of guys but those other guys
they're special especially oh and again
I think the thing that I also had to
remind myself is this is also Bill
Belichick and nobody knows this anymore
and this was his list no so he was a
part of and he had to sign off on it
nobody gives Thurman Thomas that
respected he it's you know was he caught
the ball went on to the back there was
everything he ran the ball he did all
those things that we're talking about
Christian McCaffrey is doing went to
four straight Super Bowls he was not his
father they lost he did have one
untimely fumble that wasn't that was
very unfortunate but if you look at
Thurman Thomas 12,000 rushing yards he
was fakhla Danian edge before everybody
[ __ ] yeah it's it is interesting it was
a little watch the show at the same
point there it's just the thing that I
care about this stuff is these lists
do go on and live in this regard this
list will go online and what happens is
I understand we need to remember people
for posterity and for all time and we so
it's a lot easier to forget somebody
like Dutch yeah and people likely
haven't talked about him in years since
the nineteen thirties and so it's
important to keep it going but when you
leave people off lists in this era of
the Internet where we don't learn
anything we just google and read and we
don't want to formulate our own ideas we
just look at other lists like that's
kind of what we just did that's right
like if there's somebody that's not on
this list right now we'll never will
remember them
the Corey Dylan's will get lost you know
what I mean the Stephen Jackson's will
be here's a question the Shawn
Alexander's will get lost with Emma
Smith had the same type of career if he
played on the Lions I mean that's like
the if there was first things first in
the 1990s that would have been number
one take absolutely because he wasn't he
wasn't quick and shifty like Barry he
was more of a power that's why the
argument the argument for Barry Sanders
is an easy one to make
of course here the least amount of
talent is applied when he and he still
didn't that's right and you get to play
like the weird thing with Barry because
he retired after nine seasons he still
has potential yes I I have a potential
theory that you you only when you first
step on the field all you do is lose
potential so when Duane Haskin steps on
the field he has unlimited potential he
could be a hall-of-famer as soon as he
throws that first pass it either stays
or if it's incomplete it goes down and
and that's why the greatest people are
the people that have lost the least
amount of potential yeah like LeBron
James yeah of course like LeBron James
to be in year 17 and to still have
potential left is mind boggler but there
are other people that we know like we
know what Jameis is he it's we know
exactly who he is
but with Barry there's still what-ifs
yeah it's still he's like the second
leading rusher of all time and what if
he played six more years to the please
what if he played on a good team easily
and so those are the guys that are
incredible you know Frank Gore has
squeezed every morsel out of his
potential like he has gotten more like
you know when you squeeze
any water left Frank Gore scan every
freaking drop I love Frank Gore I've
told you this story about him but yeah I
love Frank Gore because we both had I
had a knee injury in 96 so I told my ACL
in 96 had another surgery oh so this is
like pre-college in 99 so I tore my ACL
or high school day and I retort
that's why well enough that's why I was
it was noble but Frank tore his twice in
college within 18 months of each other
and for his ability to have this type of
career I mean how many years 15 years or
so now whatever it is a bunch fifteen
hundred fifteen thousand yards in the
way that he runs he's not to make you
miss type of guy he wants to run you
over he's five ten to 15 to 20 at the
most he's and it's not all muscle which
is kind of weird he's not he's not like
he's elderly Mark Ingram yeah he's not
like a Adrian Peterson what you saying
oh wow he's gonna hurt somebody's a ball
he's just like a ball or just a ball of
knives it's coming at you well high
knees that sounds scary
that's how Frank Gore used to run he's
still doing it now all of my patient
getting downhill football it was so
aggressive it you know what knives can
do gore you I know oh I like that you
see yeah that's a word that means stab
to like that
yeah puncture um Wow Frank Gore Frank
ball of knives great ball of dice hey
Frank
hopefully you keep playing because that
could be your new nickname all of knives
they know it's never gonna stick but
that's it is interesting with Frank that
he also now I see him after games and he
just like he looks like Danny Glover
like I'm too old for this yeah yeah he's
always like you guys talked to each
other I'm leaving
I love Frank Gore but he has a love for
football that is unmatched
like a student of the game knows every
position does all the things right works
out the next day wants to play football
too till he's 100 I love Frank Gore I'm
trying to see who the comparison is for
the NBA in terms of like all-time
scoring leaders of like somebody that's
at the top and they just did it longer
than everybody else like Carl Malone you
know it's a little bit [ __ ] well here's
the thing Frank Gore was never a rusting
leader he was just kind of like a the
rushing leader had 15,000 pigeon hundred
yards he had 13 on it but he's
done it for so long and it's I can't I
try queuing the average career for
running backs is three years
how did heck is he still playing cuz he
doesn't make people miss a bunch of
times
he's running people over that's what he
did how does he steal - Annette that's
amazing I know how I felt after eight
years after my ninth year I was like
yeah so me and my me and my friend this
was last week we were out and we were we
were saying name your top three favorite
Raiders running backs and doing all that
stuff then we started get on running
backs and in my favorite running backs
which are not my best but number three
of my favorite I think I went Barry
Sanders Bo Jackson Marshawn Lynch and
there's something about the I'm gonna
run through your face yeah that certain
guys have and certain guys want to make
you miss Le'Veon Bell is a making miss
yes Marshawn Lynch is a run through your
face
he was an Alex Mara is a making miss I
become our Sophia Mark Ingram is I'm a
punch in the face Marshawn Lynch was a
tone setter oh he said that tone you
remember the Legion of boom we were all
that nasty safeties physical front but
it was Marshawn Lynch to set the tone
for that football team he was the guy
that said you know what this is the
attitude that I'm gonna have this is an
attitude for the offense and defense
keep up and they found an attitude
because of him because of what he was
able to do Marshawn Lynch was a special
running back and it was big but he was
also fast he was nasty in peak to me and
I can't remember how many years Pete
Carroll Coast day before Marshawn got
there but he was the reason why Pete
Carroll was very very successful there
in Seattle it might be a big part of it
anyway of course um I'm thinking about
my favorite running backs Marcus Allen
used to be one of my favorite problems
sure anything if there's any contender
this year that has one of those guys I
only think it's the Ravens with Ingram I
don't think any of the Niners running
backs are power people know a lot of
that come on the respective fullback I
mean they do well I don't think Aaron
Jones or Jonathan Williams a little bit
maybe yeah but they're not a real
contender in my mind I don't I don't
make the playoffs the Browns you want to
put a money on it Oakland loss Browns
they got an easy schedule I
now I can't bet on Baker I just can't it
hurts me that I can't do it do you wanna
bet on a money I can't I can't bet on
you in a bit
what about Ezekiel Elliott he runs hard
he doesn't look the same that she does
but I don't think the Cowboys are a
contender I don't think the Vikings are
a contender and they're eight and three
I think they are because remember we
talked about what can we make on the
Vice stopping the run and run deep and
being able to run the football get to
the NFC Championship game ah yeah they
gotta have to go don't know don't know
you don't believe in them I do believe
in my eye they are scary good on defense
and all offensively they can get it
going cuz they have a running attack and
they got two good receivers and Kirk
Cousins at least willing to throw some
interceptions to figure it out never
forget that Kirk Cousins is the ultimate
litmus test and if you look at all of
the teams they've won their homes that
are falling below five no that's the
problem that's why I can't say they're
gonna win it but I'm just trying to tell
you every now and then Kirk Cousins gets
it going we're gonna see Minnesota at
Seattle this week before we go because
we are gonna do a pod tomorrow with
Warren sharp just to kind of talk about
the Thursday games and then also a
little bit of previewing the Thursday
games do you want to talk about them at
all I think that there's only one game
that matters I am NOT excited to watch
bears lions I'm gonna watch that because
it's football Saints Falcons at night I
doubt that the Falcons are gonna be able
to do anything but it is an Ellis in
Division game so I mean those divinity
games are tough to call but Bill's
cowboys at 4:30
if the Cowboys lose interest they go to
six and six sisters the game for these
in Dallas I feel very confident that the
Cowboys are gonna win that game I think
they're gonna win I didn't the bills win
back-to-back games the Bills have
completely turned around their style of
offense their offensive coordinator
brian de bal is now calling plays from
the booth last this past week they ran
70 plays which i think was the most
since like in like five years we talked
about on the betting show their pace has
completely changed but they are going
into a Dallas Stadium with them on a
two-game losing streak the bills now
surviving two in
where they let Miami hang around and
Denver couldn't do anything and they
were still kind of in the game it just
looks like a really rough game I would
bet on a bounce back from the Cowboys
that do the Cowboys is embarrassing I
thought they were going to be good I
don't think the Bills offense is
anything to right oh no but they run the
ball well they weren't too consistent I
don't think they you don't think they do
not really
I think the bills are the bills as I
said will be the fifth seed in the
playoff that loses in the first round
I can see that they don't have a bunch
offensively at Calallen has been good
but me Josh Allen has been he's been
good but there's been times where if he
doesn't run he's gonna something that
offense it's not effective I just I
think that's a really rough matchup yeah
but I'll be alright so we didn't talk
about the Eagles I forgot we have to do
that do we can we just skip over them
for a week they deserve to be skipped
over I'm gonna ask you as a
hall-of-famer in the Philadelphia Eagles
organization yeah am I allowed to root
for the Eagles to lose one of these next
three games against Miami Giants and
Washington just so that I don't get my
hopes up that they moved to 8 & 6 and
then faced the Cowboys only to be
disappointed or do I have to be down for
this the entire time you have to be you
have to ride with your team what you
mean you mean what are you talking about
why would you say something like that
we got a ride with your tasty if you're
if you're all they're gonna do you're a
fan right are you a fan then what do you
mean Kenny can I be down for this also
it's also like it's like I'm in a
troubled relationship you don't want to
hear and I don't want to walk down the
aisle yeah
because if I commit and they don't show
and I knew it was gonna be problematic
listen commit you got it you got to
commit to it but I really don't want to
man and here's why you have to commit
because the defense is playing at a
circus they're not playing the Super
Bowl level but they're playing much
better yeah let's talk about the fact
that Russell Wilson over through Jacob
Hollister and DK Mecca have dropped 14
points 14 points but sometimes you get
hit a couple of times that may be a
factor there
DK Metcalf has been inconsistent but he
catches a lot of ball you're called a
low ball a lot
all they did was go where's jaylen Mills
great let's throw it throw it him that's
your starting you get the guy that you
confidence on that's right
finger wagging when they drop the bottom
I'm okay with that I'm okay with all of
that I just want the Eagles to be and
what Carson wants to be better look
there's gonna be a situation I'm for
seeing it now or the Eagles they're
gonna face the Dolphins and it's gonna
be a lot uglier and God forbid this team
goes out in South Beach on Sunday night
no they're not and they start off really
slow no but I think that they don't beat
the Dolphins they survive write all this
down then they're gonna go and face the
Giants at home another close game where
they're going to survive it is going to
be ugly
Daniel jealous and they're gonna go to
Washington it's gonna be like Lane
Johnson comes back they've had Jordan
Howard and Hal Shawn back for a week and
they win that game it's a little bit
close but they win it by double digits
like a late turnover they'll beat the
risk and then they're gonna be sitting
there at eight and six mm-hmm facing
Dallas at home and I'm gonna get my
hopes up you should because you're a fan
and they're gonna lose I don't like to
matchup between the Eagles and the
Cowboys and I it's it's like I'm trying
to save I'm trying to save December Adam
like November Adam is trying to save
December Adam from pain mm-hmm
you know what be heartbroken you're
protecting your heart that's what I'm
trying to do I appreciate that about you
that's why I don't want to enjoy the
Dolphins wins and the Giants washing
protecting your heart is like you see a
beautiful woman you like now I don't
want to date her because she may hurt my
feelings that's not the way to go into
life that's not the way to date you see
the beautiful woman you go after her you
don't protect your heart you go in there
with your heart wide open and you say if
you're gonna hurt me I would rather be
hurt by something I love the
Philadelphia Eagles I don't want be hurt
by an ugly chick I'm gonna be hurt by
the best chick that's the Eagles right
now yeah but what I'm saying is I just
wanna stay home and watch Netflix and
chill I'm not even trying to talk to
anybody else
I'm just saying hey is it cool like if I
don't go out tonight yeah and like I
know that it's gonna be really fun like
you know I thought about the Eagles
schedule the Eagles schedules like going
out
a Friday night when you're not sure
after that's the world you take that
first shot you're Miami Dolphins hey man
sorry should be a good night oh look
who's walking in hey how you doing
trying to be like you
second shot Oh New York Giants oh they
play my song what's good we're feeling
all right now we're sitting here and
we're seven and six we got a winning
record here we go
yeah and then Washington comes up oh my
god she walks in and it is in slow
motion and she's got the dress and she's
looking nice oh and I say what do you
like to drink and she says whatever
you're having somehow then
Big D comes to town
[Music]
and all that joy that you've built up
she turns around and she goes that's my
boyfriend that's him after you gave it a
drink
that's him and maybe you look at your
friends and go my god you know how many
episodes of Rick and Morty I could have
watched and she probably doesn't even
drink she gives him to drink you're
right Oh oh my god I would smack that
drink out of the both of their hands
nothing more troubling than a Big D
coming oh my goodness
I'm out yeah but that's but so that's
how I look at the next three weeks right
so it's gonna start poppin it's gonna be
eight and six we're gonna be sitting
over here talking about X's and Y's and
Z's and the playoff picture and if we're
able to play Minnesota the first round
we could really shock the world and like
it could be great and then Zeke is gonna
come in there with his nose ring and Dax
gonna come in there for his hips yeah
yeah and the worst part is is I feel
like we're gonna lose because of Sean
Lee you know what I mean Charlie
yeah like the little dude that nobody
invited hey guys oh [ __ ] you doing here
hey she's pretty
you gonna buy me a drink Sean get the
hell out of here you're ruining forever
ruin it yeah we had a good thing going
before you got here that's how I see the
Eagles season look at this guy this guy
I did an appearance and this guy he
gives you it so you just handed me he
went to school with my dad
I'll laminated sheet the 1971 Dutchman
yeah and you were at a signing I went to
it I had to do my radio show in
Lawrenceville New Jersey okay guy walks
up to me said listen I went to school
with your dad this is him and I didn't
even know this until until um so it says
in court eSports published October 13
1971 led by co-captain Gary Morris Union
freshman halfback Ron Westbrook who I'm
not gonna lie
is he wearing 36 36 and he's running at
an angle that I've said you know that he
wore it in the number of 30 sweeps the
right side 12th victory in a row over
the last two seasons and over here kind
of looks like your brother a little bit
he does nice little Bush going on there
you know old school you had to have the
bullet you've never seen this before
I've never seen any of these pictures
yeah this guy gave it to me he's like
yeah play with your dad
it was awesome and here's the thing when
you talk to your dad about sports oh my
god and listen to this sentence this is
in night this is a 1971
Westbrook speed is complimented by his
past catching ability in that Mitchell
has made him a prime target mm-hmm kind
of sounds like another person I'm trying
to tell you when you talk to your father
he's always like oh I was this and that
and that and this year like yeah okay
old man and then when I see this guy
Gary Morris he's like no your dad was
that guy he was a guy that we all wanted
to be like he was a guy that we looked
up to and you never knew well I kind of
knew but your dad tells you all types of
yeah
Al Bundy stories yes ever really know
back in my day that's actually maybe we
should give more respect to Dutch Clark
in the 1930 he's definitely playing up
against newspaper boys and still don't
work early hey they had to come from
work to go to the game yeah they go back
to the work after the game that's Dutch
Clark the greatest running back that's
ever played really mock and he signed my
one banana huh that's incredible now
that banana cost you 13 cents right he
also brings and delivers our milk on
Sunday he does that's right I love when
he brings all the jugs
I would love to dip Engler I think next
week we should just do like a series
called the life of Dutch Clark and it's
just this running back that none of us
have ever seen and what his side jobs
were right yeah mechanic oh man my tires
got a flat oh my god are you Dutch Clark
yes I am man and I'm a meanest tire
changer this side of the Mississippi it
best running back in the NFL ma'am
seriously to be perfect
Dutch can I ask you a question what's it
like to score a pigskin oK we've had
enough Oh
Thanksgiving is on Thursday yes you are
the weirdest eater I've met in a long
time world dies too we are we are we are
we're in portion control but I'm gonna
name a food or a side mmm-hmm and I want
you to tell me if you like it okay go do
you like Turkey I love Turkey okay love
to
unlike my turkey fried though fried
turkey otherwise my old-school turkey
I went fried turkey this year actually
my wife is making jerk turkey what which
I'm sure would be delicious honey I'm
sure it will be just out of the norm
it's all I say but do does Brian
Westbrook like stuffing
I do love stuffing Wow I like stuffing
with a little gravy on it yes I do like
stuffing yes you have to have stuff you
know Thanksgiving
do you like cranberry sauce if you have
cranberry sauce at your table then
you're a bad person you're just a bad
individual and you should not have
guests they should just eliminate
themselves from your presence because if
you have cranberry that you are trying
to get out of the whatever came organic
well Fanta no they make it themselves
it's not like a dessert what is it
what do you eat that I believe if I was
gonna come at you with real restaurant
palette stuff everything on your food
your plate is very savory and salty no
you are not someone that mixed foods but
mixing the sweetness and tartness of a
cranberry with the saltiness of let's
say a mashed potato
okay what about mashed potatoes love
mashed potatoes love them cranberries
they create that's too bad that that
idea
do you serve mac and cheese at your
Thanksgiving
I despise mac and cheese like I my wife
always this is a point of contention in
my home that she wants to have mac and
cheese there and I'm like no no we're
not having mac and cheese we're just not
doing it you just so I can you eat do
you eat mac and cheese process with
noodles and cheese that's that's with
mac and cheese is noodles and cheese you
think that's special
Raylan can I tell you that the entire
country of Italy has made a community
based off of cheese and noodle that
there is no food that I believe is more
universally celebrated than the
combination of mac and cheese other than
maybe chocolate and peanut butter first
of all the the most celebration I will
say this was very funny is I threw
asking the office last
we were doing this with football players
too mac and cheese is not often served
at White Thanksgivings really typically
that is more of a mashed potato and what
we noticed from like interview and this
is obviously like a cert a sample size
of 50 people that I talk to mac and
cheese is a black thing and not food and
mashed potatoes is more of a light thing
really I like a good mashed potato do
you guys have like coleslaw I don't
think that we have coleslaw but I would
I would because you speak for all white
people and that's that's my job coleslaw
I know that my aunt will make like an
Asian coleslaw there's a slaw of some
sort yeah I hate everything I'm not a
good person to say what about cornbread
you like corn bread right every black
person likes cornbread everyone the
correct answer was ain't nothing wrong
they know a little cornbread yeah what
about sweet potato casserole or pumpkin
pie so I'm out on the casserole I love
sweet potatoes like that you know you
cut them up you dice them over whatever
and you put a look you don't like when
it's whipped with Marsh no no
marshmallows no good no good you don't
like marshmallow doll
no I don't know I don't like Marshall
knows it all but I don't what I don't
know mix the the savoriness of a sweet
potato with the marshmallow they don't
go to eat a s'more I have I'm not in
love with them what aspect of it did you
know I don't like marshmallows why
because there's just like empty it's
like you bite into them they're just
yeah all right so nobody likes Mars no
yeah you definitely don't want
marshmallows and sweet potatoes no good
sweet potato casserole now I'm out on it
all right so if we started off the
morning with an omelet and then at lunch
we had some mac and cheese starving and
then at night starving he had a s'more
so you would not eat any of it I would
eat none of that zero
I hate omelets I don't know if mac and
cheese is worse than your peanut butter
and chocolate take you know I wanna like
almonds because you could put all
different types of stuff in omelets so I
wanted like an omelet I hate it I hate
eggs though what about so what it not
even a kraft mac and cheese
no I don't like the smell of cheese what
if I took you to like mama fuku Nishi
and they had a pepe I like dish with
like noodle and some butter and some gin
would you
no no no matter no matter what you do
with know we're at an Italian restaurant
spaghetti and bolognese sauce
what meat sauce that meat meat sauce
with little sauces in there yeah like
that Bologna no I didn't say Bologna
that's awesome yeah meats like meatballs
with the sauce yeah nice of course what
everybody else you never get like a
fettuccine alfredo no too cheesy I don't
like the creamy sauce I like the white
wine sauce though slightly scampi's good
little always I like the little wood you
know your seafood I would but it's not
my favorite but I'll eat that got eat it
I've had um pick up my daughter just you
eat a crab dip no too cheesy way too
cheesy with their little uh yeah village
no no artichoke no no no I heard it you
what about if they have like a nice soft
pretzel with a cheese dip I like
pretzels not cheese no but I'll tell you
this I like nachos with cheese what it's
crazy
I like nachos and cheese and I love
pizza too so like every other human
being it does you don't like the gloopy
cheeses no you like the stringy cheeses
I don't like I like mozzarella cheese
but I won't eat it cold don't eat a cold
whatever it was it cheddar cheese so
your worst evening out would be fondue
front oh no I never would eat in every
never we eat bon to see you don't like
soupy okay and no no no I want to make a
bet with you that at the end of the year
the loser has to get dunked tanked into
a vat of nacho cheese really that's
that's where your mind goes yeah because
it sounds like you would really hate I
would I would be upset for a lot of
different reasons yes
and I'm upset optionally I'm disturbed
that your mind is evenly absolutely
optionally you know because I think it's
very interesting like I texture is a
thing you know yours is yours is up
there bro hey so what do you what are
you doing for Thanksgiving are you are
you cooking or no no we're gonna I have
some ants that are really good cook
so you're not gonna contribute anything
so you know I'm gonna bring down like a
New York pastry that's are a cake I
think when you live in New York you can
just kind of walk in any place and like
always that in New York yet you're like
yep right man
and they're like ooh things just taste
better when they're from the city yeah
so I'll bring one don't get me through
and catered we're getting our dinner
catered nice which is the first time my
mother was upset my wife thought of it
so there's a little bit of I don't know
there was friction well there was a
little bit of like what she's gonna get
dinner catered I'm like yeah we're gonna
cater you know how you sell it then we
got to go because we're taking way too
long I don't remember this if you say
that your wife and I'm giving you
marriage advice you tell your mom that
your wife wanted to do that so she could
talk to her more i I just I said I said
don't you want to spend more time with
us she's like yeah I wanna spend time
with you guys but I want to be able to
cook they want to cook black black
mother's want to be able to cook and
they want you to sit there and eat all
day all day it sounds amazing that sound
amazing
I'm excited how many more days before
Thanksgiving that was food talk for
Westbrook the rocket man I am the lef
koe man we wish you guys a happy
Thanksgiving you especially Brian thank
you brother enjoy it and then we're
gonna have Warren and tomorrow BIA
apparently he talked again so we're
gonna do it losses boys apparently got
that sick oh wow yeah all right let's
get the [ __ ] out it yelling at the TV
man see you brother
see you guys see you bye
[Music]